hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 17 of my payto pay flipping
Series today we're starting at about
20.5 mil uh we made some decent progress
out last episode probably five or six
mil um mainly flipping the darkness Set
uh which we will continue to do this
episode as well along with probably a
couple new items all right let's get
started okay so the first item of the
day is going to be another Darkness set
I believe just because of how good it
worked last episode kind of see the
flips there from last week um but I
think we'll do maybe the boots of
Darkness uh yeah do the boots of
Darkness now it says actively trade
place is 400k 'll put in for 500 to see
if we buy it and yeah so that was
actually accurate so that's kind of nice
to know so we bought them for 400k and
we're going to sell them
for 264k yeah that's a huge margin again
that's
135k or something so we'll definitely do
these uh put them in for about
236k or so sorry 265k and then we'll do
20 cuz we have quite a bit of time today
um we're going to leave them in for a
while next up we're going to do the hood
of Darkness um just for no particular
reason we're just picking random items
from the Set uh so we bought it for
exactly 250k and then let's see what we
can sell it for put in for one and we
sold it for 163k which is quite good for
the price it's 90k margin that's awesome
I'll do another 20 of these for sure uh
put for 164k and 20 quantity and we'll
call that
and next up we're going to be the gloves
of Darkness um now I didn't actually
check the margin here we're just kind of
guessing um just kind of getting some
practice just randomly guessing for the
items uh let's put them in
for maybe a bit lower than that I think
we're going to do 200k and uh we're
going to do 20 more of these as well um
and then we're probably just going to
move on to the last Darkness item uh cuz
why not we might as well do the full set
okay so we're going to try buying the
Robes of Darkness for
420k did not happen fortunately um so
we'll have to go put another offer in um
maybe bump it up to 500 and see if we
hends to buy
it and we did so we bought it for
exactly 500k and let's see what we can
sell it
for 39K that's another 110k margin we
will definitely do that I'm not sure if
we have enough for
20 uh not quite we'll have to do
something like 19 or something but
that's okay uh put in for
391k and yeah not quite enough we'll
have to take one off or maybe two um but
either way we got pretty close and yeah
we'll come back when we have sold some
of
these okay we are back and we made
complete Bank on this flip that was
awesome uh so we'll start with the hoods
of Darkness we still got a 85k margin on
those and 11 of those gives us
935k almost a mil from that the rows of
Darkness were definitely the best uh we
got a 108k margin we got all 20 of those
giving us 2.1 mil in profit which is
insane uh the gloves of Darkness we got
98k on each and uh five of those gives
us 490k in profit and the boots uh we've
only sold six of them so far but we get
134k on each so the hu the largest
margin and that gives us 804k so far
from the flip we got about 4.3 mil now
if we take off 5 or 600k just for
checking the margin we're still about 4
mil in profit in that one flip and it's
only been a day so that is awesome we
are definitely going to continue doing
this item it seems to be the best item
I've ever done uh so yeah let's continue
on so we're going to start by
readjusting the boots of Darkness that
we have in here right now uh so we
bought them for
325k uh so we still have 12 to sell
still uh so it has dropped a bit but
still we are still going to be getting
probably 80 or 90k on each boot so
that's another Mill we pretty much have
in our
inventory um
and I guess we're going to sell it to
and just see what the margin
is I guess we're going to buy some yeah
why not we might as well buy some while
we're at it uh we've already kind of
invested to check the margin um so we'll
go ahead and buy some more while we're
selling this uh since they seem to move
quite quickly actually we'll go buy
another 20 uh for the boots of Darkness
um and then we're going to sell the ones
we have actually we'll just do 10 um
because we still already have another 12
we should probably sell those first and
then we'll plop the boots of darkness in
for about three 324k roughly um still
giving us a solid margin on that and
another 3.8 mil to get in the inventory
okay so we're going to try the Robes of
Darkness again uh once again we bought
them for 500k and we'll sell them for
let's
see 384k so that's pretty much where
those was at before and it worked quite
well so we'll go ahead and do these
again uh so we'll put it offering for
385k and we'll do another
20 next up will be the hood of Darkness
again uh there's no point not doing this
wow we bought for
490k interesting this probably going to
have a huge margin on it oh 200k that
has a 290k margin on it right now um I'm
not sure if by the time I actually buy
this item I'll still have that but uh
we'll do it anyway and last up we're
going to do the gloves of Darkness again
still an amazing margin on them again uh
so we'll buy them for about 236k I
believe and uh yeah we can afford
another 20 it'll be perfect and we'll
come back when we' sold some more of
this stuff okay we are
back um we haven't totally sold
everything yet we're kind of Midway on a
lot of things but a couple things have
ful sold and we have still made quite a
bit of money um so the Robes of Darkness
we got a 114k margin on those we fully
sold those so far uh so that would give
us
1.02 mil 1 126k pretty awesome there so
far um we also sold the boots off from
the last flip so that's given us a 60k
profit time 12 is another
720k another the rest of the items are
kind of Midway through selling um so the
hood of Darkness we've sold 12 of them
so far it had a 98k margin it's still G
This 1.2 mil uh which is awesome the
gloves of Darkness um kind of in the
middle of selling not much as sold so
far and same with
the H Whatever item we have left um but
yeah let's go ahead we'll pull the
offers out and we'll put a new sell
price in okay so since we've left these
in for a couple days we're going to have
to readjust the prices here so go what
we're going to do is we're going to
check the margin and then we're going to
buy more of it as well as selling off
the ones we already have um so 280k we
bought it for so we'll sell them for
279k um I'm not sure if we're going to
buy more at this point I think we might
just get these offers in first um the
boots of Darkness let's see what they
have dropped
to mind you we bought these for 262k so
we're still get a 40K margin on that
it's not too bad still pretty good
compared to other
items um in last will be the gloves of
Darkness we originally bought these for
236k um so looks like we'll still be in
the profit for that uh not too bad and
um yeah we'll see what else we want to
buy this
time okay so I think what we're going to
do with the rest of our money is we're
going to flip this zamari and dragon
height Set uh it doesn't have as big a
margin as the the darkness Set uh but
there seems to be a lot traded a little
bit more anyway than this so we'll give
it a try has a 70k margin with is still
pretty good um so buy a couple of these
for
532k um we'll use a good amount of money
so we'll probably do 20 or 30 yeah we'll
do
30 and yeah this is the last day of our
membership so we actually have to go buy
a bond as well uh which will cost us
hopefully a little bit under 3 mil but
we'll have to
see and we buy it ah no okay screw it
we'll buy the bond and we'll come back
when we have actually sold some of the
stuff okay we are back and fortunately
we didn't get a lot of the Dragon sets
uh we only got five um but still 67k in
each day gives us about
335k in profit on top of that we have
sold the majority of the items we
already had uh so the hood of Darkness
we got another 78k profit on each one of
those and nine more we sold for a 702k
profit uh the rest of the items we sold
as well uh the gloves of Darkness uh got
a decent margin on that as well I can't
remember exactly what it was um and the
boots of Darkness uh same thing kind of
we didn't it's just kind of selling off
the rest of the items I'll probably
display the total amount below um it's a
little messy so it's a little hard to
remember exactly but we definitely
profited on both of those um but the
majority of it was from the last uh clip
anyway uh but yeah let's continue on
these items are working quite well let's
go so we just bought this dragon head
set for 599 and we sold it for 400k
that's a great margin so we'll go ahead
and definitely do
this um if we continue to get this
margin we'll make quite a bit of money
actually so we'll put 20 in for that and
move on to another item and we'll do the
row bottom of Darkness again um for 411k
we'll do 10 of
those so the H of Darkness has only
about 30 or 40K margin on it and I was
thinking of not doing it and then just
thinking like that is still quite good
comparatively um so we'll do another 20
hoods of darkness and we'll come back
when some of the stuff has
sold oh okay so we are back uh we didn't
do quite as well this time but still not
too bad uh the Robes of Darkness we just
broke even on since we only bought one
of them um the zamari and Dragonite sets
we got one realistically giving us 188k
and the hoods of Darkness we got three
of and giving us 30k each gives us 90k
in total um since we had to check the
margin for all this stuff uh we didn't
make a whole lot probably 250k on the
flip um yeah let's see if we can do some
more of these anyway okay so we checked
the Dagon hiide set again and it has a
50k margin or so uh which is still
pretty good so we'll go ahead and do
these mind you they haven't been buying
very quickly um but we'll still give
them one more try uh since the darkness
set seemed to have been slimming up the
margins a little bit um but that's okay
we got our serious money out of that so
we'll buy 10 of these to start with uh
so we checked a couple of the items but
looks like the gloves of Darkness still
have the best margin so we'll do 20 of
these and find something else as well oh
okay so the hood of Darkness has been
very good to us for quite a while but uh
the margin is just too slim now I don't
think we're going to do it um
unfortunately uh let's check the Robes
of Darkness we're going to buy them for
491k and we can sell them
for um 417k that's pretty decent still I
you kind of notice all of the margins
have gotten a little bit worse um but
that's okay um again we seriously milk
that for quite a bit of money uh so
we'll go ahead and buy 20 of these and
we'll come back when some of the stuff
has
sold okay we are back and um boots of
Darkness worked quite well uh the other
two items kind of didn't so much um but
so yeah the Robes of Darkness we only
got probably a 75k profit um including
checking the margin uh so not too bad
but um the boots of Darkness we got 70k
on each and we got all 20 that we wanted
to buy given us about 1.5 mil m is
checking it so it's to say 1 .4 mil so
still quite good um comparative to the
other items for sure um so I think
that's what we're going to call at the
end of the episode we are at about 26
mil probably closer to 27 once we claim
that zamian Dragonite set so that is an
awesome bit of progress for me we made
probably six to 7 mil this episode alone
uh so quite awesome I'm happy with items
we're doing now we're going to try out
some brand new ones next episode and
yeah I hope you guys enjoyed and we'll
see you in episode 18
[Music]